I know Legend Welcome to New York thank
you I love I'm so glad you're here I man
I love it so much you're living on the
west side I know it's just everything
the energy everything is very much me
I'm very I do a lot you do a lot yeah
yes that's New York too I know but
that's why I fit in yeah anything
special for Thanksgiving oh I gave up
thanksging I cancelled somebody canel
nine guests canceled because somebody
got sick oh no so so I decided I called
up my my chef friend and I said we're
not doing Thanksgiving yeah and I've
also cooked like 14 turkeys already for
my TV show you kind of done it yeah and
I still have to do one more turkey I
think on the Today's Show so little
turkeyed out I am turkeyed out I hope
you have taco Thursday or something on
yeah yeah just have we have tacos I'm
going no I made a plan U friends of a
course invited me to their home so I'm
going to about five different homes that
taste different courses you know do it
oh my God those friends must be so
stressed out oh I hope so yeah I was
like if you were coming to my house I
would for sure lie and say I cooked it
and have somebody else do it like oh my
God so this is this is crazy so your
first book came out in 1982 which is
insane like do you remember that moment
like when that was all of course that
was like a big thing for me that was my
first book entertaining uh we had a
party to end all parties we had so every
one of my friends came and they we had
set up stations in my backyard in
Westport Connecticut and everybody
cooked different things from the book
and we had hundreds of people come wow
and it was so much fun and now I'm
working on my 100th book I was going to
say that 100 books did you ever think
you'd look at that yeah that's
incredible like I line them all up like
that I mean everybody like I don't know
I feel like there's a lot of people that
get into this world that try and like
say oh I love cookie I do that but you
are the most successful at it so what is
the trick um well I I work hard I mean I
work hard a lot of people work hard I
think you're just like special every day
and I I think about it while I'm asleep
you know I'm I'm a workaholic yeah you
love purpose I like it yeah I I love
though that we um both have worked with
Snoop I you had worked with Snoop the
last time I talked to you but I've
worked with him since then I love
working with great I know he's so much
fun so I feel like in your next hundred
books that you're GNA put out you should
do one have you ever infused weed into
your Foods uh I haven't yet not yet but
I might this is a great idea know it's
so but you just have to walk you have a
person to taste test for you of course
and a provider too you know exactly a
Prov um I love this and this is also why
I want to be your friend because I know
that you did something for your
granddaughter I believe she's 12 right
yeah she had like six friends over and
you had was it an Autumn weekend
sleepover yeah a couple weeks ago she
brought five friends so there's six
girls and I persuaded them all to sleep
in the Woodland Cottage yes which is the
CH most CH oh there's Jude she she's
taller than I am now she's an amazing
girl and um and so much fun yeah and she
entertained her friends she had an
agenda it was typed up for me two-page
agenda for the weekend so she's you well
she's more than I am I mean my gosh two
pages it's making picking apples making
apple cider um organized totally
organized uh bottling The Cider then we
had lunch that I had to make I made all
the food for the girls that weekend
she's got it made and one of the mothers
came and she was all dressed up the
mother came with the do with the
daughter um and this is a new friend I
had never met this friend or mother
before and the mother came all doed up
with spiked heels and uh and I live on a
farm and she could hardly walk on the
stones she's like air rating your grass
and and when she saw how we Liv she come
next day she came back to pick her up
and she was in jeans I hardly recognized
her it was so it's a little intimidating
like your kids going over to Martha
Stewarts and you're like what do I wear
I didn't even I didn't even know she
knew I was Martha Stewart oh you know I
didn't know and one kid did not want to
stay in the Woodland cottage which is
way far from my house it's like a mile
from my house oh she's too scared and
she was scared she said I don't like
nature I said oh Buck it up you know
yeah yeah there's no that parenting gone
there's no electricity there's no
running water there's no bathroom
nothing like camping what if I have to
go pee and I said the Woods the woods
and um and and they said don't be afraid
of the coyotes or the foxes you know she
stayed out all night she was excellent I
will say I'm just like you on my Ranch
but the difference is is that we have
like um you know grizzly bear and
mountain lions and wolves like things
that can actually kill you but um but I
do I've peed all over
it cuz there is no bathroom and we stay
in Little cabins as well it's beautiful
isn't it fun yes it's beautiful we went
pumpkin picking they they carved
pumpkins no I'm saying I want to be a
friend I want to come over and do this
okay they had so much fun and they were
excellent excellent oh that's so cool
what a beautiful experience that all
those girls have oh that's special I
want you to explain though the the world
of Martha project what is this the world
of Martha project well we're just we're
working on so many wonderful new things
um our our products for the home are
beautiful uh wonderful Martha by
Martha's uh pots and pans towels sheets
I just got back from India to to visit
my men manufacturer in India with a
state-of-the-art textile factories uh it
was very fun I mean I had never been to
Mumbai have you been no I've always
India is one place I want to go oh it's
crazy crowded and crazy noisy and
colorful but um oh that sounds like me
but it's yes it's uh it's but a lot of
fun to see uh where things are being
created now yeah and we we design they
they manufacture uh we had a very
interesting
time
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home